[Music]
hello
is anyone there I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival outfit to Godzilla you gotta be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
our world is changing the mass
extinction we feared has already begun
and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world and unless all the
Titans are found our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
you are on your goddamn minds I am sorry
but this is the only way
[Applause]
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
[Music]